qu'est ce qui se passe tu as l'air
triste ils ont abîmé sa marque ils ont
abîmé constaté dégoûtée je suis dégoûtée
c'est koh lanta en plus et les légendes
c'est les 20 ans en pleurs non mais
c'est vrai alors on va au 20 mai ce qui
s'est passé myriam raconte à nos
téléspectateurs apprendront à la
réaction moore qui a d'autres chats les
conneries pareilles bourg des comptes
comme fer non mais sans déconner vous
êtes rencontrant des comptes itunes est
en train de [ __ ] là au moment une
légende mon ami qui ado de chialer pour
l'économie parce qu'ils ont mangé de de
tuque
je suis parce qu'il y avait déjà une
première photo on la voulait appeler le
délai vous gates avait que tu es y aura
qui y voit là avait fait rapatrier par
des locaux de la nourriture sur l'île
puisque lui est originaire de là-bas et
la révélation en fait les candidats
ils sont sept ils sont au nombre de sept
dont il y aura et il y aurait également
claude
malheureusement voilà ben en fait il se
serait fait rapatrier enfin il serait
allé chercher de la nourriture sur une
île à côté saint louis le où ils font le
le conseil et il s'y passe est une série
de la bouffe
ils ont même la production a pas prévu
lille de la bouffe c'est là réussi à des
macros de débat comme à celle ils sont
utiles
où ils sont c'est à pierre iata ou en
fait la bayard il ya un espèce de
complexe hôtelier à plus luxueux et un
couple leur aurait donné tous les trois
jours de la nourriture 3 je vois la
consommation la nourriture pour période
il paraît qu'il aurait dit on va vous
payez plus tard alors ça
jure que c'est vrai c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit il au rendez vous êtes vous inquiet
pas quand on rentre après on va vous on
va vous payez mobile à d'autres infos
vous allez voir il va nous les donner
dans un instant on a eu club froid dans
le dos pour nerf l'aude qui qui voit la
nuti clairement que bah il nie pas les
faits bon il les a firm pas non plus
mais bon pour lui en fait et c'est une
vendetta contre le match parce que c'est
une grande légende et que certains
connaissent la fin du jeu et que du coup
bah voilà on lui en veut et on sait une
machination contre lui ça mais bon
on va vous donner les autres infos jeu
c'est guillaume elle reconnaît encore
d'autres que des infos ça l'info voilà
momo il a des infos et momo il est pas
bien triste parce que momo il a raison
koh lanta c'est le sait il que cette
année ils ont flingué kolontar ce mardi
voilà un tu as raison de dire ça voilà
je voulais pas ta mère voilée et je le
dis je voulais pas le dire parce que
c'est des mots qui ne sortent pas de
mots c'est de la merde son koh lanta
depuis le début on à moi je kiffe le
programme là je ne sais si tu m'invites
mrc je sais mon chéri tech et mon frère
a même parlé du casting et tout ça en
même temps toujours dépourvus on a des
fonds je défends toujours les candidats
ni rien q c'est qui qui a mangé mais
savoir c'est quoi qui courent il ya des
gens qui
ses joueurs ou à ramadan voilà on sait
que c est la bête on donne les noms
témoin ouais je vais quand même utilisé
le conditionnel a pas parce que je suis
pas sûr de mes infos mais parce que
voilà donc qui aurait donc pu y aura
claude non ils n'ont sam non laurent
noro jade nom et une ba voila alors
pendant gérard il vendait à sion non pas
combat et pas tu sais que je suis fou de
pouma
quoi combat à manger
et manger que des miettes on s'alarme
n'aurait pas combat pas claude papaïx e
passâmes à 6 passes et j'en passe et ça
c'est légende ils ont mangé à isabela
d'alors ne dure
que manger que
hugo n'a rien mangé chaud alors parce
qu'il avait lara sera souvent on va
avoir un mot quand on entend ça
franchement je suis dégoûté ouais je
sais je suis dégoûté parce que j'ai reçu
une centaine de messages ce matin de
beaucoup d'aventurés de koh lanta qui
comprennent pas que d'être invité à ce
programme qui est les 20 ans des
légendes et ils se permettent de faire
ce ça et avoir ce comportement là en
sachant qu'il ya des gamins qui nous
regardent des 100 exemplaires d'air
c'est d'ailleurs cette aventure on a un
palmarès je pense à claude je pense à
laurent sur les gars qu'est ce que vous
avez foutu et fait n'importe quoi et
beaucoup d'autres candidats auraient
voulu être à leur place moi je me suis
entraîné pendant dix mois à plein patate
parce que je voulais être voulez les
challengers qui voulait pas manger je
voulais ouais
je suis dégoûtée je suis dégoûtée je
suis dégoûtée la mairesse je suis
dégoûté parce que s'ils sont dopés ça
c'est des sportifs dopés pour moi tu
vois de quoi tu arrives sur koh lanta
quand tu manges le lendemain c'est bip
bip et coyote ait eu cours un vrai papa
bien sûr oui atteint tu sais tu bois tu
bois excuse moi excuse-moi indium oui tu
bois une canne ai dit tu vois une
canette énergisantes tu vois tu vas sur
une épreuve était plus avantagée que les
autres sur moi c'est là on voit que moi
je moi je tire mon chapeau à hugo parce
que tu me regardes chapeau franchement
tu es un bon parce que vraiment c'est
lui qui doit gagner la france devrait en
parlant de risques de gagner pardon
excusez moi mais je vais pas fouiller un
peuple qui chante pas en colère mais
c'est pas grave selon eux le jour de la
finale qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire que
abc ça c'est si vous avez loupé à médard
et ont donné le titre cède 0,4 est-ce
qu'ils vont lui donner non mais tu as
raison ils vont avoir les cojones veut
dire savait pas quand tu découvres des
tu veux dire constitue donc voilà un
très brillant est-ce qu'ils vont avoir
ce courage de se dire c'est quoi on va
pas vous le donner oui on va pas vous le
donner on va on va remettre le titre
observe la raison et là il faut annuler
purement et simplement sa déjà eu du vol
de nourriture dans les saisons notamment
dans la première et la deuxième à la
première fois
ils m'ont chez l'habitant mais c'est la
première fois dans koh lanta qu'on voit
c'est à dire les gars baissé récemment
et on va apprendre d'eux deux semaines
qu'ils avaient leur part là où tu viens
chez moi la maison chanel à 21h30 bah tu
fais le feu et tué d'après
non mais sans déconner à base de hachis
parmentier buy com à
100 mais c'est n'importe quoi gilles
tanneau djoko jean alors déjà
l'annulation c'est pas la tendance que
la finale aura lieu donc la semaine
prochaine le vote de ce koh lanta il a
duré deux cent cinquante ans mais il
était absent face au scandale la
production a réagi très vite hier ils
ont convoqué et reçu alexia laroche
joubert et julien magne les têtes
pensantes tous les candidats en fait ils
ont été un peu démunis parce que avec le
co vite c'est la première fois que koh
lanta se tourner dans une zone qui n'est
pas désertines il y avait des
habitations fait ça et ils n'ont pas pu
flics et tout le monde donc il ya eu des
abus ceci dit moi je vais balancer un
nom de celui qui a ourdi tout ça s'est
longuement vous plaire cyril vous
l'adorez cet été où ira quoi voilà c'est
tout cela ternira je vous le jure
ce qui s'est passé ce qui ressort des
auditions hier de tous les candidats des
auditions
étaient où ira c'est tenir à toi ivoire
et a accusé qui a accusé certains
d'avoir mangé dans l'es7 que vous avez
donné il y en a au moins trois qui n'ont
pas mangé je peux pas donner alors le
parisien parce que c'est le parisien qui
a donné toutes ses emprunts si on le dit
ils disent que hugo aurait peut-être
aimé être dans l' histoire de tricherie
mais personne ne lui a proposé les
remèdes c'est vrai donc ils ont longé
manche en lui ouais donc donc je voulais
me l'info laurent n'a pas mangé voilà
donc c'est déjà le rendement je suis sûr
qu ils lui ont proposé de manger mais il
n'a pas mangé absolument il arrête de
manger et hewitt alors elle dit non
c'est non n'a pas tout à fait les mêmes
infos j'entendais mais je crois plus
myriam
sympa ce qui s'est passé c'est que t'es
où ira et sa famille ont juré la perte
de claude parce que claude devait se
dénoncer avec théo ira d'accord claude a
refusé la hésiter il a refusé de se
dénoncer théo ira a juré sa perte et ça
va loin parce que selon mes infos claude
a perdu un très beau contrat
d'exclusivité qu'il avait avec tf1
ça va loin et claude la fille qui
fulmine parce que il s'est dit je ne
balance pas la production lui dit ne
balance pas mais il est en grosse
difficulté donc moi je trouve que pour
se disculper dirait on parle d'une
affaire de tricherie au bordeaux gagnent
organisée oui mais c'était wira qui a
ourdi sedin et ça fait partie des dix
n'était ou la routine c'est lui c'est
lui qui a organisé les dîners c'est lui
qui dès le premier jour ira kahudi le
cri dès le premier jour il a été
chercher cyril de la nourriture et ça
c'est pas bien et bien arrivés sur l'île
à chercher de la nourriture et l'eau lui
celle où exactement il a uni le complot
et moi je dis t'es où ira devrait être
virée du jeu à bitam eterna
mobo oui je suis d'accord avec gilles
mais gilles là ou là où tu es vrai il a
eu le courage de 2,2 n'y a pas de quoi
j'étais fâché c'est qu'il a il a été
voir la prod il a dit en gros j'ai mangé
ok les autres j'ai mangé je marchais
deux fois d'avis j'ai mangé les autres
et ce qu'ils ont fait c'est un truc mais
est ce que ce sont et ce qu'ils ont le
courage que de theora de dire que j'ai
mangé courage que theora y dédiant voilà
est-ce moi j'ai grave je suis pas je
suis je suis je suis pas je suis je
mérite pas d'être là je devrai laisser
ma place aux autres et c'est donc les
autres n'ont pas eu le courage
theora il a eu le courage de le faire
même s'il est à même si même si les même
si c'est lui qui a commandité tout ça et
c'est bon il faut dire aussi que ça
reste un jeu c'est qu'un jeu koh lanta
mais qu'en anonyme
c'est peut-être un jeu mais moi j'en ai
j'avais mal au cul oui alors il faut
arrêter c'est un drame mais aussi
des missions d info si c'est pour dire
ça non non mais je vous donnais mon ami
j'ai des infos aussi parce que c'est
leur technique pour se barrer c'est
qu'en fait ils sont quand même
surveiller les candidats de koh lanta
qui avait des gardes sur l'île et qu'ils
attendaient que les gardiens endorment
pour son mari et se rend donc dans ce
complexe hôtelier particulière
il ya quand même des gars sont censés
les surveiller c'est la maman s'occupait
des gardes aux questions
que dans leur contrat c'est visible ses
marques et qu'ils ne doivent pas aller
se nourrir mais rendrait s'agit d'un
survie d'eau qui sont malins ils vont
hésiter gérard oury bah alors on a faim
lundi
déjà ils ont mis ils ont mis le mardi on
a chaque fois une arnaque absolue
arnaque absolue à la raison il a ensuite
on excusez moi mais on nous a mené en
bateau on nous a menti ici on a essayé
de sauver le soldat theora comme à
l'oral à l'ariana non mais je la regarde
le chercher avec bienveillance me donner
la gueule mais moi moi moi pour moi la
saison doit être carrément des
programmes chinoise suit on doit
recommencer koh lanta l'année prochaine
avec une nouvelle équipe et 0 je mets le
ventirad dit c'est le cas à te dire ça
va faire mal à koh lanta toutes ces
machines moi j'adore saison sombre et
plus vous adorez clos il adorait ça mais
ils doivent finalement pas bien sûr
glander
ckd l'année dernière
finalistes qui se connaissaient
et les 100 milles
à manger ascendant mais manger dans koh
lanta c'est comme si vous disiez et
travailler dans tpm paix c'est non mais
sans déconner c'est comme ça ce n'est
pas possible
tout ça pendant qu'on est potes la prod
le savez nos produits ont essayé de
cacher le truc ou pas alors moi je n'ai
rien à voir là dedans non mais vous
savez c'est le plan peut tout et je suis
blanc bleu je n'ai rien à manger même en
vrai même si on doit me koh lanta j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un manger est drôle
c'est qu'il ya certains candidats qui
ont échappé à la pesée traditionnelle a
remis ça se voyait qu'il fonctionne
aujourd'hui des béni oui oui ça se
voyait qu'il n'est pas mince et moi j'en
veux surtout pas finir la combi grands
traits peut également rêver c'est pas le
sujet bah oui moi j'en veux surtout la
prod quand le but du jeu c'est d'affamer
les candidats on peut se douter sur une
île il ya des habitations et la
tentation soit très grande il faut que
la production la production emma mettre
les moyens en place pour résumer les y
résister puisse résister de gré ou de
force à la tentation là il est garé son
dorment ou sur la vue de réguler les
gars qui sont d'emblée mais qu'après ils
vont dîner comme ça le soir trône en
cours asifa dans koh lanta mais bientôt
mais un peu tu vas aller en collant koh
lanta d'ivoire et ils vont se préparer
le soir pour aller chez moi
c'est devenu déconner ça veut dire quoi
ça non mais champ de mars et qui c'est
qui qui tient ce koh lanta c'est
françois hollande non mais c'est qui
c'est qui c'est qui oui non c'est vrai
qu'à partir du moment où il y avait des
habitations s'il n'aurait pas dû être le
15 qui n'est jamais le cas 20 koh lanta
il aurait dû mettre est infiniment plus
de garde
mais ce koh lanta il est tout à fait pas
parce que celle all star c'est pour ça
que c'est grave c'est que ces
emblématiques les légendes et c'est
comme si j'avais toutes les légendes de
tmp genre tout le monde et que vous
fassiez elle n'hésite pas là mais voilà
et c'est c'est eh oui gilles bernheim a
même donné une info et je pense que
cyril vous allez pouvoir l'accréditer ou
la démentir on m'a dit que si tf1 avait
programmé le koh lanta le mardi c'est
parce que vu tout ce qu'on leur avait
raconté vous tous qui savait dès le
début c'est à dire que les scandales
allait sortir que c'est vérolé dès le
départ avec des clans est un peu
scénarise et que du coup c'était mieux
de le mettre le mardi pour planquer un
peu pour sauver la remarque
alors là non parce qu'ils savaient koh
lanta était très fort mais koh lanta n'a
jamais été aussi faible mais toute
l'histoire de koh lanta moi quand je
vois les scores de koh lanta le mercredi
je vais vous dire je suis dépité parce
que koh lanta à moins de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs jamais j'aurais pu voir
ça j'en ai pleuré non mais sans déconner
quand tu sais que l'amour est dans le
pré fait plus que koh lanta il faut se
poser des questions en a mais c'est
qu'un problème parce que les
agriculteurs ils mangent mais endroit là
ils ont le droit parce qu'il nous
nourrissent oui là il est bien question
c'est qu'est ce qui va se passer là pour
la finale que va dire dénis brogniart
elle si ce drame et de livres honneur
puisqu'il va dire mardi au lycée lyautey
la révolution fait comme si de rien
n'était c'est catastrophe
les candidats n'ont pas avoué ça n'a pas
été filmée donc la prod récents son
droit de diffuser ou pas les images et
de faire la finale fin à partir du moins
y a pas de preuves physiques bien sûr
y'a compliqué mais ça gâche sa guise le
ca mais maintenant les gens quand ils
comptent maintenant quand tu sur notre
camp d'en face disent s'il ya de la
tricherie y mangent ils dorment à
l'hôtel alors que je suis les gens à
l'époque ça c'était pas vrai maintenant
ça s'avère vrai maintenant ce truc là
c'est vrai maintenant les candidats y
mange sur koh lanta manganèse bekri
michael holt au breda du parisien
attendre que les gardiens sont signes
surveiller mots après les votes au
conseil s'endorment pour rejoindre le
sunset beach hotel une pension de
famille qui dispose de six bungalows
avec vue sur le lagon ainsi qu'une
grande ville assure jardin louer des
touristes locaux des ex métropolitain
voilà ce qu'ils faisaient voilà ce qu'il
écrit et après ils allaient se gaver et
beau comme des porcs voilà un et des
tirs à des sous et démons sochaux qui
dormait là bas mais bien sûr si ça se
trouve il dormait l'absence à ce pauvre
chien là bas
touchés et oui je vous dis je vous le
dis ça vous le dis je suis outré elle
compterait aller à montrer qu est ce qu
ils ont redit oui fait seulement
d'accent voulez manger sur koh lanta
momo soit honnête à manger sur koh lanta
mais la façon dont il a mangé après koh
lanta
que je vais manger c'était une chèvre du
code trucks est vide je sais que non
alors on apprend des choses qu'on n'est
pas du tout pour on adore les chèvres
moment je suis au tour excellent
j'aime tourner l'attention des gardes
c'est un sport dans koh lanta non non
non non attends tu as regardé ce qu'il
dit aux gars c'est non mais oui non mais
oui non mais regardez ce qu'ils voient
là selon le parisien l'objectif serait
de protéger à tout prix l'image de
claude c'est ce que va faire la
production l'un des derniers chouchou du
public il a encore beaucoup hésité sur
la trace ta stratégie à avoir concernant
ça triche d'autant plus qu'un autre
candidat les a surpris dans le noir et a
tout raconté comme aurait pu dire que la
tentation était trop grande il a
finalement décidé de nier jusqu'à la
mort après tout les caméras n'étaient
pas là voilà voilà ce qui se dit çà veut
dire qu'il veut nier jusqu'à la mort
claude que j'aime et caude apparemment
il a mangé qui voit si tu n as laroui
est close aujourd'hui l'axé il accepte
les interviews dans les médias à
condition qu'on ne parle pas de condat
même pas à manger non mais c'est ça mais
moi par contre je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose pour l'émission ça permet de
renouveler le casting est d'arrêter de
prendre des aventuriers qui connaissent
le jeu par coeur et qui n'ont pas peur
des sanctions et ça c'est une très bonne
chose et ça va aussi permettre aux à
l'émission d'avoir des rebondissements
pardon mais le record d'audience de
cette saison c'est la prix goethe et
ouvrira alors au point il ne joue pas
dans l'émission alors je vous dis royal
est ce que dit le parisien encore à
témoin anonyme qui a dit à la recherche
de nourriture il s'est fait repérer de
nuit par un gardien du côté de la tente
des techniciens mais il a pu repartir à
moindre frais all the clothes
ouais ouais aucun des aventuriers mis en
cause micro nissan ont souhaité réagir
d'ailleurs et comme vous l'avez vous
accepteriez levitte des interviews sans
qu'on leur parle ni de triche ni de ce
caprice des dieux car ni de granola le
maudit voilà alors aujourd'hui il ya une
mise en garde de la production à qui a
dit garder un la mise en garde il faut
venir
froid dans le dos toute violation de
l'obligation de confidentialité par l'un
des aventuriers prime l'ensemble des
candidats du versement de la prime de
confidentialité 2000 euros ces frais en
gros ça veut dire c'est vrai mais fermer
google est
encore plus intimidant ils ont reçu un
courriel qui précise que celui qui
permet d en faire des informations à la
presse ou à myriam palombes à
est redevable d'une somme de trente
mille euros et cela pendant 15 ans frère
tiens bon je vais fermer ma gueule 1
bons
débuts d'émotion voire un mail nous
disant qu'on n'a pas le droit tout n'a
le droit de rien dévoiler de koh lanta
sinon ils nous attaquent à bamako
comprend maintenant alors je vous
racontais un truc c'est que tout le
monde a reçu un mail de tf1 avant le
début de la saison et de la production
toutes les productions toutes les
émissions pour dire si vous donnez ils
ont même fait une ils ont même fait une
loi début et c'est passé au tribunal
s'ils ont donné des infos sur koh lanta
ou si on donnait des spoliés koh lanta
on risquait une amende on comprend
maintenant pourquoi ils ont fait ça
puisque la sangsue la céleste c'est là
la saison étaient pipés chipy d'après le
parisien un couple était
particulièrement hospitalier en ouvrant
ses portes et surtout s'incline aux
aventuriers tf1 info exclut les
candidats auraient payé les habitants
une fois rentrer en france pour les
remercier donc je vous le dis ils ont
bien payé les années dans ça veut dire
qu'ils étaient là bas ils ont une petite
adrar d'ouest à combien tu me fais la
moussaka voilà tracteurs on avait une
moussaka tak tak et en demi pension ils
ont fait exactement au géraldine et ils
ont payé après non mais ce qu'ont voulu
là c'est fou hein ils ont payé après au
menu du salé du sucré des boissons
énergisantes un rituel tous les trois
jours pour la plupart des cinq candidats
non mes chaussures trous les trois jours
il allait manger en fait tous les trois
jours il allait se démonter là bas les
candidats craignent les répercussions
surtout pour leur image et un salarié
dalpé de la boîte de prod a tout de même
commenté la priorité des participants
c'est de trouver de la nourriture par
tous les moyens
voilà donc hélas ils ont en outre trouvé
chez un mec qui vont pleuvoir et goût à
l'aventuré
koh qu'ils ont failli se moque
d'éventuelles sanctions la véritable
légende de cette saison c'est hugo il
aurait peut-être aimé être dans les
histoires de tricheries mais personne
lui a proposé voilà alors tout le monde
est choqué bien entendu les internautes
tout le monde ne parle que de ça voilà
interrogé on a en or on sait plus aussi
sur la tricherie de thé où ira je vous
le dis interrogé par l'équipe sur place
tahrir a avoué qu'il avait avalé un plat
de légumes cuits en journée puis un
steak frites quelques heures plus tard
ce sont les caméras ne tournent à ce
moment là un autre aventurier a confié
que la production à la production qu'une
pirogue sans moteur lui a rapporté des
plats away bigorre pirogue et
à l'époque la preuve avait parlé de
papaye
alors la ceni papas et les mamans oui
c'est ce qu'on a trouvé mais là vous et
aidez la réunification des où ira a eu
une obsession il partait le matin tôt à
l'eau dans ce plan quand il cherchait
qu'ils allaient pouvoir amener de la
nourriture sur l'île donc il ya vraiment
une organisation pour amener de la
nourriture et c'est vrai ce que vous
disiez sur les candidats moi j'ai eu
trois candidats de l'émission là
aujourd'hui
ils sont terrorisés à l'idée qu'on donne
leur nom basque parce que si l'abonné
cesse essentiellement procès non non
content qu'on donne leur nom en disant
j'ai parlé à tel candidat oui parce que
la clause saute et ils ont peur d'être à
paris alors on va rappeler parce qu'ils
nous ont rejoints dès 20h55 bien entendu
les noms des settons manger myriam est
ce que tu peux nous les rappeler une
nouvelle fois
d'avancer
oui alors il
donc l'hôte et or armes jade et sam et
koumba koumba je n'y crois pas mais non
je ne crois pas pas s'arrêter là mais on
fait appel ce que je les aime tous si
vous nous rejoignez way au palais mais
sachez que ça à manger dans cologna
s'arranger c'est pas ils ont mangé par
saison faute mais ça reste un jeu sachez
qu'il y en a même un qui a mangé les
poteaux
voilà il ça à manger dans koh lanta momo
je sais qu'on en rigole mais je sais que
tu es injuste moi je vais pas dire qu'il
faut vraiment faut vraiment dire aux uns
tout le monde que ça reste un jeu
envoyé des menaces
moi je les kiffe humainement parlant
mais là bien sûr sur le jeu je les
quiches pas du tout je t'ai pas du tout
ce qu'ils ont fait bon voyage et la
vérité j'aurai fait à leur place je
serais démonter un aurait été chaque son
gamin ilan
ça et mourir et m'éclate à deux frères
mois laisse moi ce que j'aurais fait moi
dans koh lanta sur la tête de ma mère
moi oui ça presque c'est moi je fais mon
koh lanta je ramène ma mère dans l'île
en face mon frère
je ramène ma mère est fait koh lanta
avec moi mon frère et tu vas voir ma
mère effets de la pollution marine tous
les soins lacomare mon frère avec une
jeune gars comme ça une casserole mon
frère et on se démonte avec ma mère et
mon oreiller près là il part italiens
comme ça à qui je reviens de koh lanta
faire j'ai pris 15 kilos d'or
comme baxter est la vérité moi je fais
quand abraham el mada ron voilà je te
dis elle vient comme ça tous les soirs
on en grenouille
[Rires]
voilà ce que j'aurais fait moi merci en
tout cas à abobo juste une dernière
chose si si mlp été afin grand courage
et de remettre la ceinture en jeu bref
un romain des candidats emblématiques
pour le prochain quand lens a envie de
le faire toi même et prochain il faut
leur ego et je vous ferai honneur
était il y aura c'est quand même des
grands personnages adresses
numéros de vente on n'a pas caché il
avoue fait la tête bouffer sur l'île
mais ça va je dois pas gâcher les vingt
ans bonjour ce que damas que je regarde
bien sûr non messieurs en écrivant j'ai
des gamins kablia s'est désolé en tout
cas c'est d'ailleurs j'ai mangé il ya
des gamins qui m'ont regardé et que tu
manges et des gamins qui regardent c'est
la règle merci momo